men have a low bar when it comes to
Casual sexual partners Julie Bend or
feminist friend of mine she likes to
collect new stories about men having sex
with inanimate objects because they do
sometimes come up in like local news and
she has a little like informal
collection of man found having sex with
a pile of leaves man found having sex
with a bike you know like imagine it and
it's happened right so clearly there is
an extent to which men can be persuaded
to basically shag anything living or
dead but men aren't like that though
about like potential wives right so when
it comes to choosing a long-term partner
men have very high standards and care
deeply about the whole package not just
how attractive a woman is with
everything else about her or women don't
seem to have those two modes the
criteria that women look for in a casual
partner and look for in a long-term
partner are the same criteria and
actually often women will have sex with
a casual partner in the hope that he'll
become a long-term partner down the line
and I think a lot of women don't realize
that men have two modes which can cause
heartbreak
foreign